il y a finalement à droite des approches
qui peuvent apparaître là aussi
extrêmement différente est fracturée
vous avez une droite qui est plus
libérale qui est incarnée par valérie
pécresse
et qui peut être aussi un carnet sur le
plan économique d'une certaine manière
par eric zemmour qui n'est pas très loin
de ses positions là et puis une droite
qui se veut plus sociale plus
souverainiste qui pourrait être en
allant vraiment à gros traits être
incarnée par marine le pen c'est à dire
que comme à gauche une certaine manière
à droite vous avez aussi des divisions
idéologiques qui sont très fortes et
d'ailleurs moi je considère que ces
divisions idéologiques tant à droite
qu'à gauche profite finalement au seul
camp qui apparaît aujourd'hui homogène à
la fois sociologiquement et
idéologiquement qui est le corps que
représente le président de la république
le président de la république de vie se
nourrit de deux choses essentielles
finalement il se nourrit à la fois du
désinvestissement civique c'est à dire
du retrait d'une partie des classes
populaires et des classes moyennes qui
ne vont plus voter ça c'est une chose et
l'abstention de ce point de vue là peut
profiter en tout cas dans une élection
nationale à emmanuel d'un cran et il se
nourrit également de la division de ces
oppositions d'arrêter c'est que
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron est
quelqu'un qui est
sociologiquement minoritaire mais qui
arrive à être majoritaire politiquement
enfin qui est potentiellement
majoritaire politiquement parce que ben
jérôme sainte-marie là beaucoup mieux
dit que moi et parce qu'ils avaient
selon le bloc le plus mobilisés et le
plus homogène sur un corpus en tout cas
idéologique qui est de ce point de vue
là assez clair assez cohérent on peut ne
pas le partager mais c'est une réalité
politique
[Musique]